[Müzik]
bugün keyifli bir ortamda sizlerle
birlikte olmak benim için çok değerli
performans yorgunluğundan bahsedeceğiz
bugün
performansı konuşmak için önce hızlı
konuşmak gerekiyor
hız etimolojik olarak baktığınızda
eski İngilizcede Speed
kavramında gelişen veya başarı anlamına
geliyor daha da eskiye gidersek eski
Latince de siperare yani umut etmek
anlamına geliyor
özetle hız Aslında bizim bildiğimiz
anlamın ötesinde
değerlendirdiğimizde Umut ve başarıyla
ilgili bir kavram etimolojisi de
baktığımızda bunlar zaten birazdan
geleceğiz hız dediğimiz zaman başarı ve
umudu düşünüyoruz
aşırı ve Umudun ötesinde hız
niceliğin niteliğe
anın zamana
sonucun nedeni yüzeyin derinliğe
unutmanın belleğe karşı kazandığı bir
zafer Aslında baktığımızda
hisleri ortadan kaldıran bir Unsur ve
insanı hissizleştiren ve yıkan Bir unsur
maalesef
şimdi ve burayı yok eder
Buna ek olarak yavaşlık ise
anımsatır hız ise bize unutturur
insana daha çok yaşadığı hissiyatını
verir hız ama bir taraftan da insanın
hayattaki gayesinin üstünü Örter
duyguları panayıra davranışları bir nevi
showrova dönüştürür ve insan bu çağda
hepinizin deneyimlediği gibi zaping
yapar televizyonda da zaping yapar
tiktok'ta da zaping yapar sosyal medyada
da zaping yapar Sürekli zaping yapar ve
biz Telefondan şu anda da peki bu
zapingler daha çok Instagram ve YouTube
ve TikTok ortamında Devam Ediyor
İnsan bu da pingi yaparken izler
zaman öldürür ve maalesef yenilir
hız
gerçekliği yok eder
gerçekliği yok ettiği için zaman
içerisinde hız
insanı ve dolayısıyla hayatı
sahteleştirir
Dolayısıyla Biz her geçen gün daha sahte
bir hayat yaşamaya başlarız
Tabii Bununla birlikte ne gelir illüzyon
gelir
Çünkü
sahteleşmeyi konuştuğumuz bir yerde
yavaş yavaş illüzyon başlar
gerçekliği olmayan yaşamın
statünün
duyguların hislerin ve bunların
gerçekliği olmayan paylaşımları bizi
daha da sahteleştirir
ve bu da aslında şu anda deneyimlemiş
olduğumuz illüzyon ortamını daha çok
arttırır
kavramların altı boşalır ve kavramların
altının boşalmasından dolayı da biz bir
nevi
felsefesizleşme yaşamaya başlarız
aslında şu anda baktığınızda bizim
deneyimlediğimiz ortam ziyadesiyle
felsefesizleşmiş bir ortam kavramlarının
altının boşaldı ya da birbiri yerine
kullanıldığı farklılığı bir ortamı şu
anda deneyimliyoruz
şimdi performansı konuşmak için hızlı
konuşmak önemliydi Çünkü
performansın bağlamını bize hız veriyor
performansın etimolojisine baktığımızda
ise karşımıza ne çıkıyor Talep edilen
veya istenileni yerine getirmek kavramı
çıkıyor yaklaşık 1300'ler de ilk defa
ortaya çıkmış bir kavram performans
kavramı and of Fransız kökenli bir
kavram zaten baktığımızda hikayenin
etimolojisine girdiğinizde ilginç Sırlar
her zaman yakalıyoruz ne gibi
hız bize bir şeyleri Umut ettiriyor
Hayal ettiriyor Az önce hızın
etimolojisinde Bunu gördük
başarı ise iyi performans göstererek
gideceğimiz yolu gösteriyor Dolayısıyla
Biz hızla
umut ediyoruz Hayal ediyoruz ve daha
sonra daha çok başarılı olmalıyız daha
çok performans göstermeliyiz ki o Umuda
o hayale
diyerek performans gösteriyoruz
bunları biraz başınıza saran Galileo
Galilei her ne kadar dünyaya çok fazla
bilimsel olarak katkısı olsa da bir
taraftan Bu bağlamda baktığınızda
Galileo Galilei ilk defa hızı ölçen
insan
hikaye zaten ölçmekle başladı hızı Biz
ne zaman ölçmeye başladık Daha
sonrasında bu bizim
performansımızla ilişkilendirilmeye
başladı ve performansınızla
ilişkilendirmeye başlandığı için de biz
sürekli performans göstermek zorunda
kaldık Çünkü ulaşmak istediğimiz
hayallerimiz var ulaşmak istediğimiz
umutlarımız var ve biz bu umutlara
gidebilmek için performans göstermeliyiz
ve bunun da sürekli ölçümlenmesi ve
ölçümlenmenin de gösterilmesi gerekiyor
Çünkü performans ortamında görünür olmak
esastır
şimdi
performansta bir diğer anlamamız gereken
kritik kavram kıyas kavramı
kıyas kavramı Aslında baktığınızda
insanların daha öncesinde
birbirini tanımasıyla ilgili bir
kavramdı tanış olmakla ilgili bir
kavramdı ama kıyas kavramı insanların
birbirini tanımasından ziyade Ne yapıp
ne ettiğini Nasıl yaptığını
izlemesine dönüştü zaman içerisinde yani
Biz şu anda sosyal medyada sürekli
falanca Ne giymiş filanca Ne yemiş hangi
mekana gitmiş nasıl fotoğraf çektirmiş
hangi kadrajı kullanmış yanında kim
varmış kimi etiketlemiş etiketleyin
Tanıyor muyuz buna doğru gidiyoruz ve
kıyas burada bizim bütün ezberlerimizi
bozdu
ezberimizi bozunca Ne oldu kıyas Bizi
mükemmeliyetçiliğe doğru itti ve
mükemmelliğe çile doğru iterken bir
diğer kritik damara daha bastı o da
kendini yetersiz hissetme
Biz o kadar çok
birilerini izlemeye başladık ki o kadar
çok farklı statüleri takip etmeye
başladık ki sürekli kendimizi yetersiz
hissetmeye başladık aslında kendi
halimizde Belki çok başarılıyız Belki
çok keyifli bir hayatınız var Belki çok
mutluyuz çok donanımlıyız ama siz
Instagram'da tiktok'ta ya da benzeri
platformlarda ya da okul ortamında
filanca çok başarılı filanca şöyle bir
yerde yemek yedi şöyle bir kıyafeti var
böyle bir çantası vara gitmeye
başladığımız andan itibaren
hikaye kıyasa giriyor ve kıyasa
girmesiyle birlikte ama o çok başarılı
Ben ise onun kadar başarılı değilim
Dolayısıyla ne oluyor acaba Ben de
umutlarıma gidemez miyim hayallerime
gidemez miyim Ve ben yavaş yavaş kendimi
yetersiz hissetmeye başlıyorum bu
profesyonel ortamda da böyle profesyonel
ortam size sürekli başarılı olmanızı
söyler önünüze hedefler koyar o
hedefleri yerine getirmenizi ister ve
yerine getirmediğiniz zaman size geri
bildirimde bulunur ve siz o geri
bildirimle birlikte ben gerçekten çok
yetersizim çok kapasitesizim ne kadar
başarısızım hissedersiniz
İşte bu yetersiz hissetme bu dönemin
performans yorgunluğunun Belki de ilk
temel unsur kavramlarından biridir
ve Bu artan
mükemmelliyetçilikle birlikte ve artan
bu kendini yetersiz hissetme ile
birlikte zaman içerisinde
toplum bu konu bahsettiği disiplin
toplumundan ziyade bizim toplumumuz Tüm
dünyada da performans toplumları dönüştü
sürekli performans göstermesi gereken
sürekli mükemmel olması gereken iyi bir
eş iyi bir baba iyi bir abi İyi bir
yönetici ne aklınıza gelirse bütün
taytlılarda mükemmel olması gereken bir
insan prototipi var Biz önümüzde ve eğer
siz o mükemmelliği mükemmel ortamdan
birazcık uzaklaşırsanız yetersizsiniz
ve bu yetersizlik sürekli sizi bir
taraftan bir taraftan Böyle alttan
alttan alttan alttan hissettirerek
depresyona kadar götürüyor
şimdi bu mükemmel hayat
Bizim normal beşeri hayatımızı
profesyonel Hayat gibi yaşamamızı
sağlamaya başladı Biz bugün Aslında
modern hayatı bir nevi profesyonel Hayat
gibi yaşıyoruz takipçi
sayımızın hedefleri var beni kaç kişi
like ettiğinin hedefleri var ve ben beni
100 kişi like edecekken 5 kişi
like ediyorsa tribe giriyorum sıkıntı
yaşıyorum orada da kendim yetersiz
hissediyorum arkadaşımın takipçisi
sayısı daha fazlaysa da kendimi yetersiz
hissediyorum Bir nevi profesyonel Hayat
deneyimliyorum aslında baktığınızda
profesyonel hayata baktığınızda her
profesyonelin filminin bir son sahnesi
vardır ve o son sahne hızın
etimolojisindeki Umut ettiği hayalidir
kimisine göre o son sahne
Ege'de güzel bir yazlık deniz kenarında
her şeyi bırakacağım Ege'ye yazlığa
yerleşeceğimdir Kimisi için bu son sahne
güzel keyifli havalı bir teknedir
teknede arkadaşlarıyla vakit geçirmektir
Kimisi için bu son sahne kendimi bağ
bahçe işlerine vereceğim duaya döneceğim
çiçeklerle vakit geçireceğim vesairedir
İşte biz bu son sahnelerin umuduyla
mükemmel oluruz mükemmel olmaya
çalışırız ve sürekli iyi performans
gösteririz İşte bu mükemmellik
motivasyonu yavaş yavaş bizi o
profesyonel hayatım verdiği statülerle
kendi hayatımızı üst üste çakıştırır
Bizim hayatımız kartvizite dönüşür
kendinizi tanıtırken
kim olduğunuzdan ziyade hangi şirkette
çalıştığınızı hangi okulda okuduğunuzu
kimi tanıdığınızı anlatmaya başlarsınız
Dolayısıyla insanların daha çok Kredi
vermesini istersiniz gerçek hayatınızda
Siz ortadan kalkar gerçek hayatımızda
kartvizitiniz ön plana çıkar Neden Çünkü
ben o son sahneye ulaşmak istiyorum
O son sahne benim için çok değerli benim
hayalim o Buradan basıp gideceğim Ege'de
yazdığım olacak çünkü
Onun için bizim hayatımız kartvizit olur
Maalesef statüler çok önemli bir yer
alır yani bildiğiniz araba baktığınız
nasıl bir Arabaya biniyorsunuz Arabanız
sizin statünüzü temsil eder
kartvizitinizde
nasıl ve hangi mekanlara kimlerle yemeğe
gidiyorsunuz ve oradan bir fotoğraf
paylaşıp paylaşmadınız o statülerde sizi
yavaş yavaş göstermeye başlar Çünkü
kartvizitte vardır Bu baktığınızda
hangi ortamlarda eğleniyorsunuz kimlerle
berabersiniz eğlenceli bir hayatınız var
mı Yoksa sadece evde oturup kitap mı
okuyorsunuz çok sıkıcı Dolayısıyla
baktığınızda Bunlar da işte
kartvizitinizi
destekleyen unsurlar olarak hayatımıza
giriyor
kartvizit hayatı bana bir de neyi
sağlıyor şunu sağlıyor çıkıp kitlelerin
karşısında Konuşabiliyor musun
konuştuğun zaman Aa Bana ne kadar saygı
duyuyorlar Aslında orada sana saygı
duymuyorlar Sen bir şirketin ya da bir
üniversitenin bir öğrencisi çalışanı
profesyonel olarak o şirkette yaptığın
deneyimleri anlatıyorsun son haliyle
Ve o zaman da o kitlelerin ilgisinin
illüzyonu ben çok iyiyime götürüyor Beni
Ben çok iyiyim
ve İşte bu Ben çok iyiyimle birlikte Ben
eskilerin tabiriyle fevkal beşere
dönüşüyorum yani süper insana
Ben aslında baktığınızda bu performans
ortamında süper bir insanım ev kalbe
Peki süper insan nasıl bir insan
öncelikle kendine hayran bir insan Çünkü
mükemmel baktığınızda
Tabii ki performans odaklı bir insan
Çünkü sürekli başarmak zorunda sürekli
başardığını da göstermek zorunda
Sadece bu kadar mı İmajını yöneten bir
insan işte Az önce tarif ettik Ne
giyiyorsun ne takıyorsun hangi mekana
gidiyorsun hangi arabayı biniyorsun
Bunların hepsi Saçın başın kıyafetin
marka Bunların hepsi senin İmajını
destekleyen unsurlar Dolayısıyla İmajını
yöneten bir hale dönüşür
dinlemeyen bir insan oluyorsun Çünkü
benim kimseyi dinleyecek vaktim yok
benim vaktim çok değerli ben sürekli
performans göstermek zorundayım ve
mümkünse de kimseyi dinlemek istemiyorum
Çünkü dinlemek son tahlilde Vakit kaybı
onun için de dinlemiyorum
Ve tabii ki çok mükemmel olduğum için
her şeyi biliyorum takdir edersiniz ki
her şeyi bildiğim için de kimseye bir
şey sormaya ihtiyacım olmuyor kendimi
ekstra geliştirmeye de ihtiyacım olmuyor
çünkü herhangi bir farkındalığım da yok
Sonuç olarak performans Bir nevi yaşam
sebebimize dönüşüyor ve bir zorunluluk
bir takıntı haline getirir
ve bu bizi daha acımasız daha ruhsuz ve
daha Hırslı bir insan yapıyor
Çünkü bizim para kazanma ve statümüzü
koruma derdimiz var ve bununla birlikte
ne oluyor Bununla birlikte işte
yorgunluk geliyor
Bununla birlikte biz yavaş yavaş Duygu
kaybı yaşamaya başlıyoruz
Peki Duygu kaybının yaşayınca ne oluyor
yavaş yavaş Kalbe veda etmeye başlıyoruz
hislerimize veda etmeye başlıyoruz Sen
de çok duygusalsın diyorlar bize
Çünkü her zaman akıl ön planda oluyor
Kalbe veda edince ne oluyor hayata veda
etmeye başlıyoruz hayatın gerçekliğinden
Kopuyoruz
ve son tahlilde kökünden kopmuş
illüzyonlarıyla baş başa kalan bu insan
performans insanı Öksüz ve Yetim kalmış
bir şekilde hayatta kalabilmek için
savaşıyor
Peki ne yapacağız Madem böyle kötü bir
tablo çiziyorsun
öncelikli olarak Hayat bilgisini
cebimize koyacağız bu hayattan
kopmayacağız
insanı hayatı toplumu kendimize sürekli
okumak zorundayız sürekli farklı
deneyimler farklı ortamlar yaşamak
zorundayız sürekli bir şeyleri anlamaya
çabalamak zorundayız Çünkü anlamak bir
arayıştır gerçekliğin arayışıdır Peki
bunu
özetlersek toparlarsak maddeler halinde
Çünkü biz maddelere bağımlıyızdır
severiz maddeleri özetlersek 10 maddede
özetleyerek tamamlıyorum bir merak et ve
dertler
sabırlı ol sebat et
kendini insanı hayatı ve kitabı oku
kendi eksikliklerinle ezikliklerin ne
yüzleş Bunları kabul et dağlarda ve
Yaylalarda gez insanın Doğa karşısındaki
acziyetini keşfet
sade olmadan sade yaşanmaz sade yaşanmaz
önce sade bir insan ol yalnız
kalabilmeyi ve kendinle dost olabilmeyi
Başar kendini çok sevmeyi bırak
insan var oluşunu sınırlarını ve
kısıtlarını kavra kavramaya çalış nefes
al nefes almayı bil ve son olarak
hayattaki amacını bul anla ve bu amaç
peşinde git diyerek hepinize teşekkür
ediyorum
[Alkış]